Cole is an urban planner he wants to
create a small scale drawing of a city
block the block is a square with an area
of 8100 square meters
create a scale drawing of the block
using a scale factor of 0.1 so the first
thing we could think about they give us
the area of the block and it's a square
block so it has the same length and
width so we could use that information
to figure out the length and width of
that block so if it's a square so let's
imagine a square block right over here
and that this is I guess we'd call that
the length and then this is also going
to be the length it's going to be the
same dimensions we know that the area is
just going to be the length times the
length the length times the length is
going to be equal to 80 100 or 8100 or
we could say that our length squared is
going to be equal to 8100 so what time's
itself is equal to 8100 well the 81
might jump out at you the 81 might jump
out at you we know that 9 times 9 we
know that 9 times 9 is equal to 81 but
then we have these two zeros right over
here
but if we gave each of these 9s a zero
then we'll end up with two zeros in the
product so 90 x 90 is equal to 8100 so
now we know the dimensions of this
square block it's a 90 meter by 90 meter
square block it's my best attempt to
draw my best attempt to draw a square
block now that's the actual square block
it let me draw it a little bit more like
a square my one first drawing looks a
little bit too much like a rhombus so
here you go a little bit better attempt
at a square now we want to create a
scale drawing of the block using a scale
factor of 0.1 so the actual block once
again is 90 meters by 90 meters but in
our scale drawing and I'll do this in
this purple color and our scale drawing
we essentially want each of the
dimensions to be 1/10 of their original
of
their original dimensions so we could
take the scale factor and multiply it by
each of these dimensions right over here
so ninety times 0.1 well that's just
going to be nine this right over here is
1/10 1/10 of ninety meters is going to
be nine meters and so this when we draw
the scale drawing at the scale that kool
intends to draw it at we would draw nine
meters by nine meters and so let's go to
the actual tool and draw a nine meter by
nine meter square our nine by nine
square we can assume that the units here
are in terms of meters so let's see I
can draw a net dimension okay oops
all right of nine there and let me use
my mouse instead of my pen tool it'll be
easier and then let me make this nine
this let's see this side nine and then I
can make this side nine and then we are
all set it's a square we see we have
four right angles and now we can check
our answer and we got it right